-Performing his hit
"I Wish You Cheated,"
give it up
for Alexander Stewart!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ I'm anxious, kinda sad ♪
♪ Hard to be your best when you
lost the best you had ♪
♪ Spending days
just on my phone ♪
♪ Wonderin'
where it all went wrong ♪
♪ I'm nervous, pretty wired ♪
♪ I said your name too much,
now my lungs got tired ♪
♪ Thinkin' maybe I'm to blame ♪
♪ I just need someone to hate ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh oh-oh, you made this
so damn hard for me ♪
♪ You and your damn honesty ♪
♪ It got me thinkin' ♪
♪ I wish you would've cheated ♪
♪ And smashed my heart
to pieces ♪
♪ I wish I had a reason I could
hate your guts for leavin' ♪
♪ I wish you were the villain ♪
♪ A psycho with no feelings ♪
♪ So how do I move o-o-on ♪
♪ When you did nothing wrong? ♪
-♪ Ah-ah-ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Wish you
did something wrong ♪
-♪ Ah-ah-ah ah ah ♪
-♪ But you did nothing wrong ♪
♪ Know it's messed-up,
kinda bad ♪
♪ But I wish we didn't talk,
and you just left like that ♪
♪ I'd be angry instead of numb ♪
♪ Damn it, who have I become? ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh oh oh, you made this
so damn hard for me ♪
♪ You and your damn honesty ♪
♪ It got me thinkin' ♪
♪ I wish you woulda cheated ♪
♪ And smashed my heart
to pieces ♪
♪ I wish I had a reason I could
hate your guts for leavin' ♪
♪ I wish you were the villain ♪
♪ A psycho with no feelings ♪
♪ So, how do I move o-o-on ♪
♪ When you did nothing wrong? ♪
-♪ Ah-ah-ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Wish you did
something wrong ♪
-♪ Ah-ah-ah ah ah ♪
-♪ But you did nothing wrong ♪
♪ In the middle of the night ♪
♪ I start to fantasize that you
would ruin my whole life ♪
♪ Oh-oh oh-oh-oh ♪
♪ 'Cause you're the best I had ♪
♪ And I keep runnin' back
like a damn fool ♪
♪ Tryin' to change your mind ♪
♪ You were all mine ♪
♪ Can't believe I ♪
♪ Wish you woulda cheated ♪
♪ And smashed my heart
to pieces ♪
♪ I wish I had a reason I could
hate your guts for leavin' ♪
♪ I wish you were the villain ♪
♪ A psycho with no feelings ♪
♪ So how do I move o-o-on ♪
♪ When you did nothing wrong? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
That is how you do it!
Come on!
Alexander Stewart!
"I Wish You Cheated" is out now!